Stronger than steel... able to stop a speeding
bullet...
It’s a bird, it’s a plane!
Its … Spiderman?
Hello Everybody, Crystal here for DNews.
Those of us that are not entomologists probably
don’t have any love lost for spiders unless
their superpowers are helping us fight or
escape from bad guys.
Now, thanks to actual (not comicbook) science,
spider silk could help us do just that.
The silken material spiders use to build their
creepy webs is a complex form of protein fiber
that does more than just catch flies.
Using specialized glands spiders produce their
silk from a protein rich liquid that is dried
into solid filaments by an external portion
of these glands called spinnerets.
This process is dynamic and spiders can produce
different “types” of silk depending on
whether they are weaving a web, creating an
egg sac, or planning a ballooning trip to
another location.
Whatever the purpose, the supermaterial spiders
produce is strong, flexible, and lightweight.
It can also stretch to many times its original
length, contracts when it is exposed to water,
has a greater tensile strength than steel,
and produces a mesh strong enough to stop
a bullet.
All this makes spider silk an attractive material
for use in things meant to reduce the consequences
of physical impact like body armor, vehicle
airbags, and football helmets.
But spider silk has some super biological
applications too.
Its acidic nature gives it antimicrobial properties
and it’s also nonantigenic, meaning it does
not trigger an immune response in the human
body.
This makes it an ideal candidate for use in
medical engineering.
In fact, prototypes of spider silk enhanced
synthetic tendons, cartilage and ligaments,
as well as surgical sutures and sealants already
exist!
So why can’t we go out and buy a bolt of
the stuff?
Well, until recently it was really hard to
make a lot of it.
Research into commercial production of spider
silk has been ongoing for a few decades, but
while the silk worms that produce fibers for
commercial silk can be easily raised for harvest,
spiders are not so cooperative.
Imagine trying to raise thousands of territorial
and predatory arachnids.
Even if you could keep them from fighting
and eating each other you’d still have to
anesthetize them and hand milk them for their
silk …. no thank you.
Scientists have tried all kinds of crazy things
in an effort to produce spider silk on a commercial
scale, but my favorite one involves goats.
I mean, obviously...
Professor Randy Lewis at the University of
Utah, has bred genetically modified goats
to contain genes from orb-web weaving spiders.
These goats produce spider silk proteins in
their milk that can be harvested like traditional
whey.
Other organisms that have been modified in
the hopes of producing enough protein for
commercial viability are silkworms, bacteria,
and yeast.
Now, each of these approaches has its problems,
but they are not insurmountable, so we may
see spider silk enhanced products in the market
sooner than we think.
In keeping with the theme of spider appreciation,
check out this video from Julia, about some
of the strangest spiders in existence